so this crushed on LinkedIn and so I  figured I would expand on it here in my  other socials this is just real like I  see it every [ __ ] day forget about  [ __ ] politicians I'm talking about  like day-to-day CEOs and like VPS of  sales like enough of this like one thing  that absolutely must be eliminated in  The Next Century is that people think  fear is some great [ __ ] driver to get  [ __ ] done I promise you in the end love  always wins safety always wins Comfort  is going to win I'm motivated as [ __ ] I  don't need to scare my people into  getting there I understand there'll be  some comments saying well you're wrong  I'm [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of my  people all the time and we hit our  numbers short term  short term there's a lot of [ __ ]  sprinters out here when life's a [ __ ]  marathon when building a meaningful real  [ __ ] company is a [ __ ] Marathon